yeah so you've been to America yeah it
was literally like I went to America I
had one day back yeah and I went cycling
for nine days I had one day back and
then I went to Hawaii and now I've got a
few days back and then I'm taking my
parents around a little bit of Japan so
I don't know why I'm paying rent I'm
kind of just scamming myself yeah and
last year we spent a total of like how
long in Japan because we spent a lot of
it in America and traveling around by
half a year about half a year what you
know I I'm gonna try and at least have
like a one or two months this year where
I just don't leave you in you say that
well I already yeah I mean or at least
make it so the visits out of Japan are
short yeah except for probably when we
go to America again for ax and stuff
like that we're going there Joey's not
going to join us this time though you're
going to Vietnam Loki actually really
[__] jealous actually really jealous
and be like damn that Joey God damn it
here I am in America again for the 50th
time and Joey is back enjoying me back
in America
you know maybe maybe I'll ride around in
a Vespa in America who knows and just
get run off the roads are you scared to
go back in America after being grilled
at TSA oh yeah you know like I got
[__] diddles I I I I I had like my
guard down this time we went to Hawaii I
don't know why just because we've been
to America so many times that I've
forgotten how intense it could get yeah
you're in like hardest difficulty of
papers please
you were struggling all the correct
paperwork and they still grilled him
yeah yeah I had all the correct
paperwork uh and I was like it's Hawaii
people are chill here it's an island
it's a tropical country I know how
things were people are very chill uh my
uh my border control officer was not
chill uh okay to paint the scene right
I'm at the front of our three-man line
yes and there's three desks yes there is
two men who look quite intimidating and
they they just don't look happy yeah yes
and there's this woman who seems very
pleasant and is talking very friendly to
all the people yeah yes and I'm in my
head I'm like man I sure as hell I hope
I get the very pleasantly yeah right
yeah sure enough I go to the the
pleasant woman two seconds she's like
what are you here for business what are
you doing podcast cool bye have fun in
Hawaii I was like sick yeah so I go
downstairs because you're not allowed to
wait and I'm just sitting there like
like [__] it's been like 30 minutes
where the [__] are these boys yes
there's no way they're growing them for
30 minutes because the line wouldn't
[__] move well I mean I always get
girl when I go to the states
yeah so so I rock up I see kind of
having an easy time I'm like yeah it's
chill it's Hawaii and I give my passport
he asks uh so what are you here for I
say business and he goes what are you
doing podcast exactly the same answer as
Connor said but he went further he was
like what kind of podcast what do you do
and I was just like oh I mean have a
podcast where we kind of talk about
let's see this is where you [__] up
you've already sang too much one would
answers you gotta say one word answers
yeah just say anime anime you [__]
lie yeah I mean it kind of just like
okay
don't lie don't lie like this is
simplify don't talk to them yeah because
the guy asked me as well and I just said
Japan culture stuff yeah yeah that's it
three words the more you talk the more
they'll talk to you
yeah this is a trick with TSA chat right
I'm telling you this is well I I because
I figured this out if you just if you
start like uh um uh yeah I mean I guess
I talk about anime and stuff and he's
like well actually I want to trash taste
you don't talk about anime at all
I felt like I was in Like a Phoenix
Wright where he was just like there's a
lie here somewhere yeah there's a
contradiction uh should be calm yeah
short simple answers they'll they'll be
like okay cool yeah because again like
we okay just a preface we this is
obviously assuring you have all the
documentation yeah they're still gonna
Grill you because it's part of that job
which we did but you can you can just
make this easier by just just kind of
just being simple being frank don't open
up the [__] essay yeah see because
like I was kind of you know I already
knew because every time I go to the US I
always have to get sent to the the
second yeah I knew I was just like you
know what I'm just waiting for him to be
like come to the back with me so I was
you know what does the bathroom look
like what's the nicest back room you've
been to yeah
honestly probably
but it was so funny because like I got
sent to the back room in the Hawaii one
as I always do and they're like all
right just sit here he's already used to
this yeah this is like not my first
rodeo at all and I was just chilling
there you know just waiting for my name
to be cool just hanging out you know
watching these other people who clearly
look like they're [__] their pants
I'm like oh first time
all right guys I'm a veteran don't worry
about it and uh and you know this tsa's
office is walking back and forth and one
of them stops and just like looks at me
dead in the eyes and I'm like you're
gonna call my name am I good to go and
he just goes is Aki with you today
I'm like no
and he's like all right and he just
walks off and I'm like please put the
good word on in for me you know who I am
and sure enough like 30 seconds later
same guy walks out and he goes all right
you're good to go oh and I was like my
man he's like I go out meanwhile as I'm
in that first part we're in the line
with the three of us you know I'm just
waiting for the guy to like just tell me
the inevitable and I'm hearing in on
God's conversation and he's like so uh
like what conversation did it come to we
have to explain among a publishing
company to a TSA officer like what did
he ask you he basically so I know the
exact moment where I was just like I
[__] up basically because he was
asking me all the questions and you know
that was fine but he just kept going
right
um because I feel like he was looking
for something
some kind of horse something he could
grab onto so he asked me what do I do I
said anime uh anime and manga podcast
and he was like what are you here for I
was like uh anime convention and he was
like what's the anime convention and he
was like Hawaii con and then he goes so
uh where's cool icon taking place what's
he what's the address actually while I
was going through my thing I heard him
you being grilled of like how will you
get there yeah how will you know where
you're going and I was and to be fair I
was actually like I wasn't panicking I
was actually like pretty calm I was just
like sorry sorry about this uh let me go
check it now uh and I uh I was normally
I changed my SIM card to like a SIM card
that works in America now uh with
American data after I land uh and so I
was like let me let me check it quickly
no I would just like connect to the
Wi-Fi he's like there's no Wi-Fi
you cannot check your phone there is no
Wi-Fi and I was just like um is it okay
if I change my SIM card he was like no
what is the address I need to know now
and I'm just like holy [__]
I'm like he's [__] playing Donuts in
my mind I was like dude chill
you could just been like ah my someone
else in my party knows yeah yeah so
that's that's literally what I did and
uh he was like he looks behind and he
was like is he with you and this one
obviously wasn't a good look he's gonna
like [__] drag this wasn't obviously
wasn't a good look be me he's like he
sees me and he sees my mate Joey also
being grilled what's he gonna be taking
the guy who's gonna take it in the
background yeah
the guy taken to the back room he's like
that's your boy that's your boy right
there yeah the background yeah
I'm like uh Joe what's the Convention
Center Court again uh and he's uh on
another convention center and it's uh
yeah the Honolulu convention center and
I was like oh it's a Honolulu convention
and he he was just like how are you
going to get that how yeah I heard him
grilling you yeah yeah he he kept he
kept asking me how am I going to get
there and I'm like and I I didn't know
what he was asking for so I was like I
thought I thought he meant where are you
staying so I was like I don't know like
how like are you getting a taxi or
something yeah yeah yeah yeah and uh he
was and so I was like oh I'm gonna get a
taxi to
um a taxi to The Modern Honolulu which
is where I'm staying beforehand and he's
like no how are you gonna get there and
I was just like what what I don't know I
don't know I understand with anything I
don't I don't understand what you're
looking stupid dude like sometimes they
like occasionally they're not pretty
normal question is you know do you have
any cash on you yeah yeah so they can
trick you that's what the guy asked me
yeah yeah they asked you there because
they want to know if like I guess if you
need to do something yeah you can you
know do you know what got me through
what because actually if this wasn't my
first time in America I probably would
have been [__] myself but I know
he's just doing his job
the lawyer told me this as well like you
have all the documentation yeah you've
done everything incorrect like yeah
they're just trying to intimidate you
yeah they they if you have all the
documentation yeah you haven't said
anything that's in like outbreaches your
like terms of that Visa or whatever then
they you know they shouldn't do anything
yeah I mean like like in my mind I was
just like this is not legal advice by
the way there's not legal advice yeah
this is my like I said it's my first
time I definitely would have been
[__] myself but I was just like oh
this is this is very much an
inconvenience right now and I know it
was it was just because I it could have
easily been sold if I had data on my
phone and it just was one of the
airports that did not have Wi-Fi at the
border so you know I was just in a
little sticky situation but I was pretty
cool how I wanted you know how I want
him over why start complaining about LAX
oh
wait how did that even come up
um what's your least favorite airport
because he because he asked me um is
this your first time in America and I'm
like no fly to uh fly to La all the time
I just did a tour of America as well
this you know I've been through I've
been to the Border enough times
obviously he's like checking that as
well and he's like oh
how does how does this airport compare
to uh he asked you there he asked me
that he asked me that he answered that
and I'm just like I'm gonna lie to you
uh this is uh this is way better this is
this is such a good airport officer
okay and he looks around and he goes
really and and then I just I don't know
and then I just start going off in LAX
and I'm just like you you don't you
you how good this is compared to LAX my
God oh my God he didn't ask me I'd have
been like bro this app was a dog I'd
have been like he'd been like denied
yeah
what and as soon as I was like going off
my LAX he just looks at it and goes all
right you can go through hope is not too
hard I was just doing my job I was like
yeah totally understand that yeah
totally understand man uh totally
understand you're just doing a job
unless you saying that oh yeah yeah yeah
at least he said that you know he was
pretty loud with you there I I I don't
know if it's doing his job we get a
little something out of that he was
pretty loud he was definitely being very
loud and in my opinion very excessive I
think my my monk training kind of like I
kind of like came through maybe maybe
like exuded onto him somehow because I
was he was grilling me and I was just
like you know I'm sorry man I can't
check it right now I come here in peace
line through LAX dude I watched two
episodes of Maiden Abyss while I waited
in the immigration line
because I dude it's so [__]
so bad how like understaffed LAX is yeah
I'm like I'm like this is so stupid that
I can watch an hour of anime in the
[__] line and you got to like the uh
officer and you're just like I'm sorry
obviously I just watched made into this
it's a better episode I think I was on
like episode 102 as well and I was like
[__] this is just heating up I almost
made the best season two wow anime talk
it was good yeah yeah
how far are we in
I guess we can do animation okay we can
do a little bit of anime let's not talk
about the anime